so my clue to those of you who saw it
was that we've been talking about factor
that's where we begin and then we notice
that there are special bumpers Prime's
right and they clearly have a special
role for instance these squares of
primes
these guys are demonstrably different
from the squares of numbers they're not
prime squares of compasses okay so my
clue was if with the math fact is that
we think about primes then a logical
next step is what is the prime
factorization of every one of these
numbers okay and can that yield us some
insights and boy can it ever right so
with me now doesn't take that long
because these numbers are fairly small
let's write down these prime
factorizations okay well you don't have
to really write the prime factorizations
Freddie these guys because they are
either prime or they don't have any more
factors okay once we get to four what
we've made by the prime factorization is
can you factor it down until all you are
left with is prime numbers so 4 is 2
squared okay so I factored it 2 times 2
and those are numbers are both prime so
I'm done okay all right
6 what's the prime factorization of 6
mm-hmm 2 by 3 I'll skip down to 8 prime
factorization of 8 to 2 times 2 times 2
2 right
this is 3 squared 2 by 5 all right you
see where I'm going here now 12 you
might think first of all that's 3 times
4 but of course for is not prime so you
would factorize it over the whole and
say that's 2 squared times 3 we tend to
try and write it in ascending order
because this one's a bit ok 14 7 15 3 by
5 16
two times two times two times two right
that's pride
what's a team that takes people for two
times 9 which is 3 square that's prime
22 squared times 5 3 by 7 2 by 11 11
feeds 24 what's this bed word you might
think ok 3 times 8 3 is prime
8 is 2 cubed so it's 2 cubed times 8 and
that leaves I drink you touch 3 sorry 2
cubed is 8 and then 5 squared just for
the kicker
36 2 squared times 2x squared alright so
now let's try and see some patterns okay
you remember I've tried to link the
number of factors I get and I'm
wondering if there's something in the
prime factorization that tells me
something interesting ok so the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
look at what's in common for example the
4 factor numbers I want to see what's in
common between them and their prime
factorizations right so for instance
here's a number with 4 factors and
that's the prime factorization ok this
is a this is a cube here's four factors
this has 4 factors this has 4 factors
let's see what else we go for four
is that all than others so there's the
factorization okay now just for a second
do you member we notice all squares are
a bit funny
oops we're a bit different okay cubes
are also a bit different so if you for a
moment just forget the fact that we have
a cube in the list I want you to look at
all the rest of the numbers that have
four factors what can you tell me about
them let me listen up for you two times
three hands four factors two times five
has four factors 2 by 7 3 by 5 3 by 7 2
by 11 those are the numbers which have
the factors right they all follow the
same pattern do they not it's always 1
prime times 1 prime 1 times there are no
powers involved right or I couldn't say
the powers are all 1
does that make sense ok I keep following
the pattern ruinberg the rabbit hole
little fern up right let's look at these
numbers which have more factors okay so
for instance list out all the ones with
the 6 factors there's a 6 factor number
right there's a 6 back down there's a 6
phantom all the 6 factor numbers they
also have a similar kind of structure do
you notice that when you boil it down to
just the primes okay it's something
squared times something else something
squared times something else something
squared times something else
are you starting to get suspicious I can
have a look at this guy this is the only
one on the list that has nine factors do
you notice that
and again the prime factorization is in
a different kind of form right so here's
the pattern I notice here's the pattern
others how do I know that there are four
factors this no but I notice the powers
of both one I'm going to add one to each
of the factors right this is what you do
this perform that gives me two and two
I'm gonna multiply them that gives me
four is that okay let me show you what I
did again one at one those are the
indices of the prime factorization
I'm gonna add one to each of those two
to multiply keys before
watch it still works down here right
look at the indices right there's a 2
and a 1 if I raise them both by 1 what
do I get
3 3 & 2 I multiply the mature and I
think it sinks
how about this guy over here does it a
cat for this this little weirdo right
does it work it does 3 & 1
you bumped they're both both up by one
gives you forward to it you multiply I
don't need to prove this one do i weird
night comes from it comes from 3 times 3
so here is what I'm going to UM I'm
going to give a conjecture I'm gonna
give it to injections okay the number of
factors a number has right so far all
the numbers on my list is small enough
that they're all in this form okay where
a and B are primes
I can write all the numbers on this list
because they're fairly small I can write
them all in this format for their prime
factorization okay if I have a number
like that I'm going to suggest that it's
number of factors number of factors is
bump up one of the indices by one but
what the other indices index by one and
then multiply them okay now you can test
this out
pick a number that's not on the list
okay because we've you might be bored
one two three five find out okay picking
up any number you like okay obviously
it's gonna be more interesting if it has
if it's a compass it's on bones okay
doesn't work picking on like 40 right or
52 or anything you like list out its
factors right does it work does it work
okay go just test it up and down pick a
different number to the person next to
you just so you get something different
by other founders and see if they line
up there is no magic everything has a
reason so this is going to be where we
finish off this little exploration out
deep thoughts about a simple simple
object okay why is this magic word why
does this magic trick work I'll show you
okay save you a bit of time I want to
think about 24 I like 24 lots and lots
of factors so what's interesting okay
you remember we said all factors come in
pairs they all come in pairs right so
these factors actually have
relationships to each other right so I
was a bit unhelpful I was purposefully
unhelpful by asking you to just just
list them out right because when they're
in a list where they just they're in a
pile you can't see the relationships
between them okay it's part of why you
remember under probability if you're
like okay I'm like flipping coins over
and over again right we asked you guys
to draw these things we call them
probability tree diagrams right because
you could just list out if you flip a
quick three times you could miss that
tail tail tail tail tail head tail head
tail and honor right but listing them
out doesn't give you this
insights into this structure and
relationships as drawing a diagram like
this does right so now we're going to do
is ask you to draw this structure and
we're going to fit in the factors of 24
and you will see their relationship and
hopefully you see why this magically
gives us how many factors you've got
okay look at the facts in 224 look at
the prime factorization of 24 now here's
the crucial idea all of these factors
are built up of some combination of
these guys if you like two cubed and 3
they're your building blocks and you can
only build from them but you can combine
them in any way you like and you'll get
these factors okay so how do we do this
prisoners another like - it's one of the
factors right it comes to taking one of
these and none of these you see that
well have another like 12 okay that
comes from taking one of these and what
else I need two of these that'll give me
12 right so I want to lay this out in an
orderly way he's the way I'm going to do
it I've got none of the threes or one of
the threes that's how many choices I
have when it comes to building my
factors right I have none of the twos or
one of the twos or two of the twos or
three of the tubes that's how many I can
choose from okay now if I take these
guys and combine them
I'm going to get all my parents watch -
they're not time to see the dawn what
excuse me - they're not times 3 2 1 3 2
1 is 3 right let's get going through
dark times - the one that's - and this
is always going to be 3 times 4 in the
other night 6 4 12
824 these are the factors of 24 and I
know I haven't missed any
right now couldn't you see why it's M
plus 1 times n plus 1 what what are in
it in what are in here M is 3 for
instance right 1 2 3
why do I have to add 1 because I've got
1 2 3 here I have to add 1 because I'm
missing 0 right that's n plus 1 here is
plus 1 all right what about em it's this
second index here 1 right so yeah and
that's me
and he's and plus 1 so why do I multiply
M plus 1 times n plus 1 it's because
that will give me the exact number of
columns and the exact number of rows to
give me all the factors right well with
this table look like it's gonna be a 3
by 3 isn't it right for I should say 3
by 3 okay you're gonna have to to the
north to the 1/2 squared across the top
3 to the north 3 2 1 3 squared down the
side okay and that will give you a grid
of exactly nine factors okay so this is
simple object right factors climbed up
this but there's real depth here and
that's why I could magically say look I
have no idea what the number is okay but
I can tell you right now that 2 to the
power of 24 times 3 to the power of 3
whatever that number is it's gonna have
exactly a hundred factors can you see
why because if I bump this up every 25
if I've got this up in before and I just
multiply and that tells me I don't know
what they got but I can find it and I
can know I haven't missed any right
that's deep I don't even know what the
number is let alone when its factors are
but I know how
they're off